all right I have some new tour dates to
announce uh we've just added a third
show in Milwaukee on September 9th at
the Riverside Theater tickets for that
are on sale now I'll also be in Oakland
California Akron Ohio Washington D.C Las
Vegas Nevada
um some of those have new shows those
are all at theovan.com
t-o-u-r and thank you so much for your
support new merch for you merch heads
out there we've got some new shorts
that's right the Rat Life shorts and
blue salmon and sand
we've also got the new tie-dye be good
to yourself teas in aqua creamsicle and
indigo
get that in more only at
theovinstore.com
Morgan Wallen uh cut his hair
he cut his hair
and we don't know why
we don't know why
but we are
we're praying for him we're with him
still
so okay
we love him
um
good day good evening good afternoon
good time good tidings to you wherever
you are
man uh Happy uh August
to your mid-august can you believe it
can you believe it that school's back in
can you believe it that life is just
continuing to happen
life just life just keeps happening
life is like hey guess what
and you're like what
and it's like bam more life
it just never stops giving you more Life
That's Life
unlimited life
hey you want another scoop of Life boy
and we are happy to be alive though I am
I'm happy to be alive because this is it
you know I make that choice some days
some days I don't
but some days I say this is it
and how am I going to handle it
um
the other night a guy was giving me
directions
and I'd I'd pulled over and I was
talking about something and he was
explaining where something was
and he goes it's right over there behind
that
um
and they had a lit up sign it said flea
market that's what the letters on the
sign would say
but some of the letters had were burned
out
and this guy was um
I don't want to say homeless but I would
say
semi-homeless
or hadn't you know this guy probably I
bet this guy hadn't been home in
probably
12 or 14 months
so he was like a street baby
and so he was trying to give me he'd
tell me where this place was that he'd
went to and he goes it's right over
there behind that
um
and he sees the big sign
on this kind of building space that says
flea market
but some of the letters were burned out
so it just said f l
m
and then k-e-t those were the letters
you could still see
so instead of just deducing that it said
flea market the guy's like well it's you
know it's right over behind the um
the
um uh
um
right it's right if he goes if you go
right behind you see that uh that
um
foreign
cat
and I'm just thinking like this how did
this guy not know
that this Sansa is fully Market
just the ver I mean he was like it's you
just go behind the uh
just go you go right around there and
you'll be there he said you'll you'll
and you'll get there
and uh sorry I don't know that just made
me laugh uh food
you got to go right if you go right
behind the food
I'm good
you'll get there that's where it is it's
behind the good
so flea market
flea market anyway I don't know what
that all meant um
good to be with you happy school time I
know a lot of you uh a lot of you you
have children going back to school or
you're going back to school
um some of you've never been to some of
you can't read
and that's why you listen to things
um
but God do you remember it
do you remember it
going back to school
it was such a big time you know I
remember first you get your clothes you
got the big thing was getting school
clothes
you know
you get school closing you would set
them on the bed you had to see how they
looked how does this with that
dude sometimes I would even I would lay
down on the bed and I would lay my
clothes on top of me
instead of just because I you didn't
want to put them on
you you didn't want to break those you
didn't want to be in them until that
first day of school
and so then you know you would get you I
would lay there in bed and just have
them on me
how do I look I'd make my brother come
in the room
how do I look I'd have them all just
laid on me
you know almost like I was just
um
deactivated or whatever deceased
I'd just be laying there with all my new
stuff on me I'll do a look
um and then that first day when you wore
the clothes that was something crazy boy
you put them on you're like this is it
we're ready
and we had to get to the bus stop that's
something we had to do for for school
we had to get to that bus stop
and you know if you because my mom would
be gone my mom would leave a note hey I
went to work or I've left you guys
it'd be something note kind of like that
um there's peanut butter in the fridge
it would say yes something where you
were like okay we don't have a chance
you know
um
and then I'd put my book bag and I'd
have to run to the bus our bus was it
was probably about two good real blocks
away you had to go two full blocks to
get to that bus stop maybe two maybe
maybe two and a half blocks
and I don't know if you have maybe some
of you guys have done like a uh
10K or a 6K or whatever
hell maybe some of you have done a
couple grams of of K of ketamine you
know some fish scale and uh
you know and just laid on your back you
know semi-erect on some on a stranger's
balcony I don't know that something that
doesn't matter but what I'm saying is if
you've ever been in like an Adventure
Race if you've ever done a 10K or a
tough mudder or you know uh March of
Dimes
um or a wad a CrossFit wad you know
those are tough things to do
but nothing
is tough as being let's say a fifth
grader
with a heavy backpack
who is running
to get to the bus stop to not miss the
bus
who is running to not miss the boss
because here's what starts happening you
get going
and you're going and you're doing good
you're like [__] I'ma learn okay I'ma
learn soon bullfroot my Curt
I'm Gonna Learn but then that heavy
backpack it starts going it's too heavy
it starts kind of wobbling too fast
behind you
so now the backpack kind of has like a
energy of its own and you have to
basically you almost have to stop let
the backpack come to rest
and then get going again
you know because you look like a [__]
you look like a penguin that's just you
know
that's done a gram or something that's
grammed out baby
um so that was always the most hectic
was whenever you were late for the bus
but you had that huge heavy backpack and
it was just like it would start be like
it would come around to the side you it
was so like
like it was crazy when you were seeing
your backpack it would swing all the way
almost in front of you on each side as
you as the different legs of yours move
forward you know
because it was just getting out of
control and you'd have to stop and let
it settle down
and then you start going again
um
so that was always that was harrowing
dude getting to the bus that was a
that was the toughest thing and then
here's the crazy part as you are
approaching the bus stop
you didn't want to run because you
didn't want people at the bus stop
seeing you run to learn
because that was the most nerd [__] you
could be doing
like oh this dude running to learn
we're gonna this guy is not this dude is
a narc you know this guy is trouble
this guy wants a future
that was frowned upon
so you would have to like hurry but not
as soon as people like were looking you
couldn't you had to stop hurrying like I
don't care if I miss it I don't need to
learn
you know what I'm saying bro education
is for dummies man
food marker to make it
so uh so then you had to kind of slow it
it was just this crazy like in our
neighborhood it was just this crazy
thing to get over there you know
it was this crazy thing
and I remember one time somebody stood
in an ant pile at the bus stop and
somebody's daddy came out and um
put uh gasoline all over them
to help him out or whatever
um but that was a crazy thing I remember
about getting back to school
it was just such a harrowing time going
back to school was just such like a you
know you were going back to school it
was your that was where the world
happened
that was where you touched Society
that's where you learned where you had a
chance at meeting a a spouse or
something you know or a
whatever
that's where it all it was like that was
the the Greek the center of of of
existence that was the nucleus that was
the core of your Earth at the time going
to school
and yet then you'd get on the bus that
was crawl
dude I remember I get on the bus and it
was scary at like you got on the bus
and first I remember our bus was it was
black and white children on our bus
so first you had like these two chicks
they were both pregnant in each of the
first seats the first seats was for
chicks that was
pregnant pregnant or semi-pregnant you
know what I'm saying
um
and so you had I remember one time we
had these chicks we had Tiffany and we
had largish
and both of them they had been
somebody lit them up with that seedling
baby you know what I'm saying
that zygote baby
somebody freaking you know
put that baby that uh somebody put that
goldfish in the bowl on them babies
so you had them too then in the next CU
head like this brother this dude he had
knocked both of them up so he was right
there you know this dude [__] inmate
Crandall I think was his name this bro
he was
you know and that's a crazy name for
somebody but that was the name they they
knew about to jump this dude where he
was headed bro
so that was it that you know that was it
so you had and I remember that dude for
50 cents he'd let you see his wiener
or
he would just show you his wiener for no
money
so he wasn't like the best businessman
but
but you had to see a little bit of
weiner if you wanted to get past that
second row of seats right
and that you know that's just what it
was like on the school bus
so you had to you'd see the girls you
kind of do a little prayer for them and
The Offspring or potential Offspring
you'd see inmate Crandall you [__]
nodded him maybe peaked that Wing if he
was showing root you know and then the
next seat
it was like a mixed kid right and that
was like okay this is
because when you were on the bus you
kind of were walking past the seat so
fast you it was hard to make choices
where do I sit am I cool am I not cool
it was almost like
it was like where God put you in a
filing cabinet
or where life put you in a filing
cabinet of how cool or whatever your
status was in the world at that moment
like do you sit by the kid who's playing
a a game boy or a sweat you know a game
boy at the time would you okay do I sit
by him that dude's a nerd do I sit in
this seat sometimes you sit in the seat
and they'd have a call you know some
weird kid in there you know
we have my mom's missing
you know and you're like oh [__] dude
you know and the kids got [__] rope
burns on his wrists and [__] and
you know you're like what are you is
everything okay at the house and he's
like we love Houdini you know he's just
saying like
you know we watched David Blaine videos
or just something whatever somebody told
you know his captors told him to say or
whatever and then
um
you get to the next row and it was like
two girls that had just gotten their
first thing of [__] lipstick right
and their moms was on pills and so they
were
they were just like just had made their
lips like as big as just
I mean they just
as big as mine and you're like okay do I
sit by the jocks the jocks seem real
cool they're you know I don't know I
don't sit there it was kind of where you
figured out where you sit you know
you know do I sit by
you know the girls know it's hard it was
like oh God that's a cute girl she's
kind of quiet
you know
then there was some kid like who had a
broken arm or something like I'm not
[__]
sitting mold bad luck Hanson right there
that dude but that was always a crazy
time I remember getting onto the school
bus and being like okay where do I sit
am I cool am I not cool and you couldn't
get to the back of the bus was like the
old kid so you had to so if you weren't
old you had to figure that out before
you got to the back
you know and finally you duck in
somewhere where just somebody seemed
safe enough or cure or just nervous
enough or uncertain enough as yourself
and you'd sit down and you make sure
okay I got my book bag I'm okay I got my
shoes on I got my hands on
everything's fine
you know and you'd sit there and you
just look forward
and then the bus driver would they would
just somebody would you know call the
bus driver
um
and uh
and I don't want to say it but I said it
and that's what somebody would call the
bus driver and then she would stop
she would stop boy because I think she
questioned her sexuality and she would
pull that [__] over
and that's when it got insane you know
and it was like I just want to go to
school I can't [__] live like Mad Max
every morning
just because I want social studies
but God that was harrowing man
that was heroin getting to school
and then remember you would
sorry it's just school time so I'm just
reminiscing in my head remember you
would tell the night before whatever you
talk to your friends okay we're gonna
meet we meet by the overhang by the tree
we meet right there we meet at 8 10.
right that's when we get it's like
smooth as could be everybody knows what
to do but then you would walk you'd
start walking up and everybody's meeting
at the same spot and you're like I don't
know what to do
and then some kid runs up and it's like
some kid named Damien or whatever and
he's like our house burned down
and you're just like what in the hell is
going on
oh
oh it was just a lot man
the first day of school was a lot and
everybody had their new clothes on you
were so scared about who was gonna look
at you who was thinking about you
make sure you walk normal Left Right
seem cool seem cool are you cool no
you're not pretend you are [__] that
was the kind of [__] that was going on
in my head
seem [__] cool [__]
what is wrong with you you little [__]
huh
I will chew your ass cheeks off of your
off of the back of your wiener you
little [__]
that's kind of what like the voice in my
head would be like it would be like
scene cool
and I remember one year I had so much
acne dude my whole face was just acne
and like if I smiled
like four pimples would pop it was
it was I was afraid to make any
fate like crazy facial
things
like any I don't know what they're
called like what's it called when you're
like you go like you know like ooh you
know her
um exclamations I guess
so
what else do I remember about back to
school
if you guys have some back to school
moments that you really reflect on once
you hit the hotline with them people are
trying to make a special clip next week
that we can put out this just about that
but yeah I remember that back to school
it was just nothing like it
was just so it was such a the build up
to it was just insane
and getting there and
and sitting in your desk okay I'm safe
I'm in my desk
you know and you just I I never wanted
to be alone I always wanted to be with
somebody with a buddy walking with a
friend like because if you were alone
and it felt like you were susceptible to
anything
but if you were with some friend you
felt pretty okay
not here by myself
God I just remember all of that
um
[Music]
yeah just drive around the food kit
feeling cute
do you mean flea market
um
what's up
yeah I know Morgan Wallen cut his hair
and we can't handle it and we don't know
how to deal with it
but you know what it's not our thing
it's his hair and he can do what he
wants with it and we just
I don't know we don't know how to feel
about it because it's something new but
that's okay
what do we have in the universe is
happening today
um I want to thank you guys I want to
thank you for just for coming out the
places people have come out recently
um
okay man some of them have just
we went up through like a bus tour
through up to Atlantic City and
Uncasville uh Connecticut
um
and I think that's that British came
over and did that
um
the British dude they and I know why we
got to get over there and perform in
Britain soon but
can you believe being British has to be
wild you know
because you don't really you don't have
any superheroes
you don't have really any superheroes
you have
you have Paddington Bear right
which I kind of get he's like this kind
of like
a little just like oh hey
you know kind of little
oh kind of
I'm Paddington you know he's like
whatever you know he does his thing or
whatever and then who else Sherlock
Holmes
so [__]
if those are your superheroes no wonder
we left to start America
we're like [__] y'all got Paddington
and [__]
uh Watson's daddy over here Watson's
pimp [__] s lock Homie we out
I'll get on a boat to Nowhere if those
are my superheroes dude
so
um
but what else are we talking about other
news
um
oh Barbie people seeing Barbie movie
and somebody asked me they said hey
buddy you seen Barbie
you seen Barbie movie
and I said no I haven't seen it because
well I'm an adult male
I'm an adult male
and I'm not seeing Barbie movie
because I'll tell you why I think it is
for children or gay children
um or child gays or whatever I don't
know I don't want to offend anybody I do
not know the terminology
um
and it's Barbie
and I'm an adult man
so I don't want to see it
and people are like yeah but maybe you
should know I don't want to know about
look when I was a child
if a man saw a Barbie movie
then your mom was going to leave that
man
and that's how you got a stepdad
people were like hey what happened to
your dad well he saw the Barbie movie
and my mom read between the lines
and realized he was probably rubbing
dudes off by the Shoney's and so now
we're getting a stepdad
um what else in the news Lil Tay is not
dead
uh I don't care
I don't care if Lil Tay is dead or not
dead honestly I don't know little Tay
I don't know little
little whisper a little
little
[__] I don't know any of these people
okay I don't know who they are every
week one of them's Dead Or Not Dead you
know many they're like oh Manny Ricky's
dead year Minnie Ricky died
a little muskrat took a couple you know
somebody popped him with that chop
you're like oh damn little muskrats gone
damn every other week you see you know
little titty got popped
they got little titty he was at a donut
shop or something in Memphis and
somebody [__] rolled up on him with a
bazooka full of Cove and [__] killed
him
every week it's somebody
a little nickel or something
or twisted uh
you know uh Twisted biscuit they got him
yeah they got biscuit
yeah he was they called him he was
walking to his car and somebody [__]
popped off on him
little dick ball they got little dick
balls you saw him they got little dick
balls again
oh bro damn tiny Benny they got tiny
Benny boy you seen that
yes he was uh he was at an ATM over
there behind the Wendy's and some goons
rolled up on them they got tiny Benny
R.I.P tiny Benny
every week it's some tiny little mini
baby
getting oh
every quit naming yourself little tiny
mini baby
oh they got little dunk they got uh many
uh many Patrick they got him
oh they got baby Zaire or somebody
[__]
every [__] week little tiny mini baby
dying
can we get one week
where they don't kill somebody named Lil
tiny Minnie baby
God damn bro
no one likes a weird beard
you see somebody sometimes you say dang
what's in your beard boy
you got a sparrow living in there what
is that
I heard something chirping I heard
something eating a worm
well manscape now sells beard products
keep that beard clean keep it tidy the
leaders and below the waist grooming
change the game they're headed north of
the Mason deck some new family that was
a bad pun
but they got the beard hedger Pro kit
and now they're going a step further
with a brand new handyman an electric
face shaver for a quick and convenient
way to achieve a clean shaven look
beautiful looking for something dare I
say smoother look no further than the
manscape's new handyman face shaver so
to get 20 off and free shipping with the
code Theo at manscaped that's 20 off
with free shipping at manscape.com and
use code
t-h-e-o hit the refresh button with man
escaped are you picking up burgers and
hot dogs for a summer barbecue
you know you're already doing it so why
not get cash back for it with Ibotta
that's right Ibotta
ib-o-t-t-a gives you cash back on
hundreds of grocery items from produce
to personal care to Pantry Goods Pantry
Goods so you can make sure you're
beating inflation no matter what you're
purchasing that's right either link your
loyalty account or upload your receipt
after you shop and get your cash back
it's that easy wow the average Ibotta
user earns a hundred and twenty dollars
per year that could cover the cost of an
entire shopping trip or you could use
your cash back to buy that flight you've
been eyeing that game you're dying to go
to or the fancy dinner you've been
craving
that's right you can earn cash back on
hundreds of online Brands and retailers
too when you start with Ibotta including
Lowe's Macy's Sephora Best Buy and more
right now ebata is offering our
listeners five dollars Just For Trying
Ibotta by using the code Theo when you
register that's right just go to the app
store or Google pay Store and download
the free ebotta app and use code Theo
that's
Ibotta in the Google Play or App Store
and use code Theo
what else
um great shows in Chattanooga that City
I gotta say unbelievably uh amazing and
beautiful Community there if you've
gotten to spend any time there and
Chattanooga
my mother used to live out there and um
and she uh so you know she used to live
in the Hills over there somewhere doing
something spending time with some man
and it wasn't my daddy I didn't know
that man
[Music]
um
[Applause]
but God what a beautiful place we had a
great we had a great time there then
went over to Memphis and did some shows
over there Memphis is you know it's uh
it's Memphis baby
you know you'll be you know somebody
they'll
you'll be having a fish you'll order or
order you a coat of fish somewhere have
two bullets in it like damn bro
this thing got popped down
you get you a little carp in your left
foot you know
somebody somebody been damned just down
Beat It To Death like God
they killed this thing has brass knuckle
wounds on the side of it
um
went to Graceland
and that was pretty impressive you know
it was just just beautiful to see
you know Elvis I mean as much as he
spent his life
um
uh you know and he reaped a lot of
rewards he had a beautiful home there
and a place for his mother to be and
um
it was just fascinating to see it just
kind of this place that he that was
peaceful to him
you know apparently he didn't Elvis
didn't drink much
so uh and when he was at home he didn't
party much in Graceland it was just a
kind of a place to relax his family was
there his mother and
um
and grandmother I believe lived there
so that was a place that he was kind of
like a rest but for him a relaxation
type of place and
um
yeah so that was just just incredible to
see what was hip and what was vibey at
that time
and uh it's a great thing it's it's a
great little tour if you get to go see
it and then his grave is right there I
didn't realize that so you go through
this man's home and then you step out
and he's right there you know he's
he's there next to his family and
just powerful
and just how much how much he committed
to entertainment but yeah we had a great
we had a great time over there in
Graceland
um
you know I want to take a moment to uh
to just express my my sadness for uh
Maui and for Hawaii
and for Lahaina in the township there
that really was just devastated by these
fires I've gotten to spend some time
over there it's a beautiful place
and
um it's just heartbreaking
you know it's heartbreaking it's really
interesting how this happened or why or
because a lot of there's not a lot of
natural fires over there
um a lot of it's usually man-made
our man calls you know and so uh I don't
know that doesn't I guess super matter
just the fact that um I know there's a
lot of people over there who are
struggling or who have family that are
struggling
um and just uncertain
uncertain that they had something occur
and now they don't know what to do
you know
they used to be so sure probably of
things and now some of the uh
some things are vague they don't know
you know and just that uncertainty um
it's just got to be really tough so just
thinking of those folks today and uh
uh just taking some time to open my
heart up to the world and and and and
and share those feelings that uh just
maybe I can take some of the pain that
any of them are feeling or any of us can
you know I think that's what I try to do
sometimes when I'm praying for a group
or thinking about other people I
you know I say hey God you know I'm
healthy enough today if they have extra
pain let me have some of it
if you can take it off of those folks
you know I think it's what we all kind
of do when we're praying that's what
prayer kind of is to me
it's like saying hey I know there's some
there's too much here probably for
someone to handle how can is there
something I give me a scoop of it
you know
give me a scoop of it Daddy
and uh
but yeah I'm gonna
hopefully find some places to donate
online as some of that stuff gets a
little clearer as to like safe places to
donate because a lot of scammers come
out and but anyway just letting the
people of Maui and Hawaii and uh Lahaina
know that um
that they're being thought of and I I
know that they are by many uh so anyway
just want to express that
um
yeah I mean one of the Wild Things in
London they have this big beautiful
Banya tree
[Music]
Banyan
tree in the Lahaina fire
it just be it's just it's this tree that
I mean it's got 40 trees built into a
tree
it's like a trees like hey
watch me work
that's what it's just like it's
unbelievable
when you see this tree you're just like
God how did it do it it the the branch
will go up and then the branch will come
down to the ground and do it just it'll
become another tree into the ground
it's like um
it's like a bunch of trees uh
it's like a bunch of trees just being
buddies it was an unbelievable it was
like a group of trees
it was like tree Six Mafia dude it was
you were like how is this a gang what it
this is unreal
um
yeah it was just unbelievable if you can
look at this tree
there's some pictures of it right here
if you're on the YouTube and just I'd
never seen a tree like this I didn't
know what tree could do this kind of
thing
and so that was very impressive um but
anyway it's just an example of the
ability of nature over there when you
get so close to Nature
and you're right up on that nut
that's what Hawaii is boy you're
balancing on Nature's nut
I mean it is [__] natural boy
you put your ear up to the ground and
that [__] will tell you what [__]
secret
you know it's just Hawaii there's no you
are in the day you are in
in the in the damn vulva of creation
right there I mean Hawaii Hawaii's it's
unbelievable
it's the only place where you could fall
down on the ground and get better like
that's how much Nate that's how rich the
soil is
you'll fall down and get up and you're
[__] you stronger than you were like
God damn
you know it's just that kind of a place
um
and if you see the footage over there oh
anyway God I mean this looks like the
end of the Earth
[Music]
I mean of course A lot of these videos
too they try to make it seem so much
crazier but I mean this is unbelief this
looks like
post-apocalyptic or something
I mean this it's on if you haven't seen
this
it's unbelievable
yeah just heartbreaking man really
really heartbreaking and I I'm sorry I'm
not trying to bring people's day down
but just trying to you know say let us
take them take take a moment if you have
you know and I'm not trying to tell you
what to do everybody's got their own
things to think about and pray for but
that's something that I've been uh this
has been on my heart and on my mind
all right let's take out a call right
now
um as always the hotline is
985-664-9503 yeah here we go
hey Cleo man
you know I just kind of watch your show
when Chattanooga had a great time and
Landon Geller hey thank you for coming
over there to the nooga you know them
new girls boy everybody was out there
and
um
beautiful city
beautiful growing city if you are
looking for a place to get in
you can't get in early there still but
you can still get in pretty early I
think it's going to be one of the
um
I think it's been one of the biggest
cities
30 years from now
Chattanooga boy get your noug up
so onward
and I just wanted to tell you something
you know I've been compared to you a lot
and I know um I love him man
oh praise God brother I love you too man
and I love you like a straight person
loves another straight person buddy
that's how I choose to love you
from a distance and in separate rooms
buddy but I do love you thank you buddy
let's hear more but the thing is you
know my dad he used to take me to the
grocery store
and when I would go I'd sit in a cold
food aisle and I'd wait for a woman to
walk by while my parents were uh
while my parents were grocery shopping
and I'd just sit in there and I believe
for women to walk by oh yeah buddy he's
a pervert
that's what you are
and that's okay buddy cuz
me too
let's hear more
every time a woman walked by in the cold
food section you get to see their
nipples get hard you you wouldn't really
know what to do but I just wanted to ask
you if you ever did that before if you
had anything like that
thank you buddy oh buddy when them
Perkins what him sprouters boy when that
lady just
just launched them front stems homie
that's what I'm talking about
them long freckles baby them nipples uh
yeah I like seeing them
God when they get close by that cooler
and you they'd be pick up that sack of
tater tots boy
and you'd see them down
you'd see them Tater tips boy them
nipples start looking
and a nipple when it pops out boy is it
if you a man nearby you think that
thing's looking for you
you're like hello
yeah when she would when she would
launch them [__]
them little titty straws boy them
nipples I liked them buddy I like seeing
them and it was yeah it was exciting
buddy if you lurking in the cold food
section
a little pervy but kind of chill
and that'd be the crazy part if you saw
one in your mouth just still pursed up
cat food cat
cat
sometimes you just don't have you you
got the letters but you ain't got the
words baby
cat boy
um yeah I love seeing them I'm glad you
like seeing them dude I'm glad we can
talk about it in a safe space like this
as two adult men that are not we're not
lurking in frozen food anymore
I don't need to do that
you know
I don't need to [__] write dirty
messages in the uh condensation and
those things over there by the ice cream
just right you know you want it
you know and people see that they're
like God damn boy
or you know
let me love on that little low on that
low monkey
you'd see us you scribble that into a
damn uh
into the condensation in a frozen food
section
and you see a beautiful lady I happen
upon that
hey Mommy
let me love up on that low monkey
praise God baby thank you brother thank
you for that call and I'm glad you seem
to be doing well
uh
uh let's take this call see what we got
hey Theo my name's Grace I'm Grace I
love that
I love that
and some people at different churches
they don't respect people from other
churches and that is called racism
when people have racism they don't want
they ain't offering Grace to everybody
no they're not so onward an Alabama girl
but currently living in Hawaii
um and I'm actually coming to your show
in Chattanooga and bringing my Filipino
boyfriend with me oh damn boy
mommy popping that Pinot out huh
that Filipino and I've always wanted to
create a wine called Filipino Grigio
and how that hasn't been done
and how that you know that that there's
not a Pinot out there
a Filipino Filipino
hell there's not a Filipino
hey Filipinos hey hey hey hey some kids
they they they confuse jalapenos and
Filipinos you know they're like hey give
me I want the hot dog with
um a couple of Filipinos on it huh
you know some people are like yeah I
want that hot dog with the uh put two uh
put you you know a couple of them
Filipinos on there
hey bro hey hey hey
let me get a hot dog with uh
you know put someone in Filipinos on
their bid Pinos on that big Pinos on
that [__]
okay sorry ma'am I'm losing it today I
was in the cold plunge earlier could be
real honest and so I'm [__]
I'm feeling alive and I'm grateful for
that
um and then we're going to go down to
Alabama to visit my family but what's
the best way to introduce my Filipino
boyfriend to my family everybody's very
white and um
I don't know I'm super nervous about the
whole I guess interracial thing as bad
as that sounds like my family's not
racist but still just like a different
culture oh yeah I know what you mean
honey
yeah it's not it's just day a little bit
of daytime racism baby what you're
talking about that's nothing you know
nothing violent nothing crazy just you
know every now and then you know it's
like you got something stuck in your
teeth you didn't even have any meat but
you just have
they're like what is that damn
is that an inward you know I'm saying
you just you don't know sometimes you're
like
that hat you know that's from previous
culture sometimes we still get things
stuck in our teeth uh just because other
people been
having beef you know
um but yeah I think the best way
probably to introduce a Filipino to some
whites
well uh
God I think first of all reveal do a
gender reveal
that's what I would do hiding behind a
tree let everybody in your family guess
what ethnicity is going to be and then
run him out there
you know
now the crazy thing that happens
sometimes if you run out of because look
there's a variety of Asians we know it
they're making more Asians every time
you crack open a book there's another
you know
or you crack open a tunnel somewhere in
Vietnam and they got six you know two
and a half new Asians in there you're
like damn
you know they're always reconfiguring
they're always moving a molecule here
you know carrying the one moving the
decimal next you know
you get Korean North Korean uh uh
Guatemalan Filipino
Asian North Asian Korean you got
Vietnamese Chinese chimpanies
um
uh
who else oh Malaysian what that all of a
sudden
you got Malaysian you got
something in front of Asian
you know uh you got Vietnamese and you
got chin Asian you got negration now if
you meet somebody that's an agration
that's new
there's some of them
um but there's all there's they're just
you never know things are God is doing
so much that they're just unlimited
Asians have been I've met so many new
Asians it's unreal
it is unreal boys
um and all of them beautiful beautiful
Asians so that's what I would do I would
do a
uh ethnicity reveal where you put them
in a box or put him behind a tree
um and then you let your family guess
what ethnicity is going to be
and then get one of those smoke things
and maybe it makes
I don't want to say yellow smoke I mean
that's you can't do that that's racist
um
just you know what don't do the smoke
thing have him come out from behind the
tree
and say here he is
uh
yeah but if people guess make sure they
don't guess anything real racist that's
that's going to be uncomfortable you
know so but yeah I think you can handle
it and I'm excited for you guys and
you know I think having a little Asian
baby is beautiful
you know I used to have a lot of dreams
and there were Asian children in them
and nothing was illegal in it and it was
uh
it was
it was cool man
you know there's just something about an
Asian Where You Are
you want to just you wanna
hmm you want to do that to him boy you
want to get it right up volume hey buddy
I love you I love you
you want to treat them well so but no I
appreciate it and I think uh
yeah and Filipinos for they are the
um
I mean they're just so good
they're so good
I read somewhere
I think it was graffiti or something but
it was like if you break open God's
heart
that there's probably 30 Filipinos in
there
splitting an orange
or just dividing up a bag of fruit or
something
you want to keep your hair Morgan Wallen
lost his hair
we ought we you know who what who what
you know who did it why they did it
why they did it
keeps helps men keep their hair two out
of three men will experience some form
of hair loss by the time they are 35
years old more than 50 million men in
the U.S suffer from male pattern
baldness
keeps has more five star reviews than
any of its competitors that's incredible
that's right
keeps his expert recommended hair loss
treatments it's really simple
do you think you're going to lose your
hair then you should get started early
if you're already losing your hair then
you should get started now that's it man
when it comes to hair loss they have
low-cost treatment plans that are
affordable typically half the cost of
Pharmacy prices
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash
t-h-e-o to get your first month free
keeps.com slash Theo on September 23rd
and 24th the pilgrimage music and
cultural Festival will return to the
park at harlinsdale Farm in Franklin
Tennessee now celebrating its ninth year
Festival Headliners for 2023 include
Zach Bryan The Lumineers
my boy Wesley Schultz over there The
Black Crows Nathaniel Ratliff and the
night sweat and many more tickets are
currently on sale at
pilgrimagefestival.com
uh pilgrimage music and cultural
festival September 23rd and 24th in
Franklin Tennessee just 20 minutes from
Nashville I'm so excited I'm taking a
weekend off a touring to go to that and
I'm very excited about it
um my uh friend Kevin Griffin from
Better Than Ezra which is a band that
I've always enjoyed
uh
uh they uh he puts it on they put it on
they're going to be playing as well so I
went last year man it was really uh
something else so I'm excited to be
going to that it's a great way to spend
some time or or get to Nashville to
listen to music if you're thinking about
doing that
what else do we have here
as always hotline 985-664-9503
[Music]
it's Joey from Canada hey Joey and we
did a show out there in Edmonton Canada
and the smoke came and they canceled we
had to move it by a whole day and to
everybody that came there for that first
day and we didn't get to perform for you
I'm very sorry that was a tough one
that was a tough one and that was a wild
show I'd never been in front of that
many folks
um
learned a lot
Edmonton is real into Edmonton is
you know that was
they want to be a big city so much they
want to know but and they are they're
respected they are
you know they're up there at the North
they're like as North
as you could get and they want to have
crime they're like we somebody got
stabbed the last last year
they say stuff like that
and there's always Sirens going on
there's like siren like fire trucks go
by in police but there's nothing's going
on
that's the crazy like I think they just
hire all these Sirens to go
[Music]
and the cops would be like we gotta go
there's a murder there's a embezzlement
you're like what a real there's nobody
here who's doing it
but there's constant like
whoa some guy jumped off a building
nobody did just there's they want to be
they want it's like they want to have
some violent crime but they don't have
enough of it so but a beautiful place
wonderful people
um
okay let's hear more
I just want to know if you have any tips
on
masturbation you know I've been having
some some trouble
lately you know I just want to know if
you're having tits gang gang you've been
handing that yam huh Joey
you've been handing that yam huh big dog
you've been uh you've been burping that
sweet potato
you've been burping that sweet potato
boy
oh you've been burping that sweet potato
you've been petting that [__] little
chicken pandery
foreign
[Music]
yeah look I'll tell you this man A lot
of times
I'm bored I'm Restless
you know yeah yeah
and it's sad but look I'll tell you this
every time you jerk off you take a part
of you you take the [__] cellular
most bright most con the most the most
the core of you you take it and you
spray it into the into the dirt
you tell mother Nate you I look I don't
care look this is what I think if you
hold on to that gas em baby if you're if
you're a uh
if you if you gather your gasmas baby
and hold them [__] close you will you
will have a power inside of you
you will have some Integrity inside of
you boy
and next time you burp that yum Seco
it's gonna you're gonna you're gonna put
it somewhere where you mean it
put put it womb it
get you a love and warm it up
who knows why we have a lot of the
problems we have these days because most
of our best nuts
is in the plumbing
one city had too much nut in it where
was it
City
I don't know it might be urban legend or
whatever or even just a white Legend I
don't know who started it but
um but I don't think we're supposed to
be jerking off brother
I've never jerked off and been like man
way to go bro
I think about it like this and I wonder
if you saw an animal somewhere
some kind of animal
what if you walked up on a lion bro you
lions are tough man
they're Brave they're fierce
right they rule they rule
and you walked up on a lion
and you saw him
jerking off
right he's got his Mane off it's sitting
on a nightstand or something next to him
you know he's probably just had a thing
of frozen yogurt
there's other women in the distance who
who'd love to meet him
but he just jerked off over there
somewhere
and you're watching him look at a screen
and jerk his body off
and bust that [__]
and bust that freaking
that little sugar nougat right out of
him
and just bust it
just
[Applause]
[__] good
it would make you sad man it would make
you sad and I think that's the same
thing that God or not I'm not trying to
put like a Godly pressure but I think
that's the same thing at the eyes of the
University when they look at us
sometimes like damn bro
and I think it does something to us over
time it weakens us I really do I'm not
blaming anybody's [__]
I spent my whole 20 breaking them
breaking these nuts off
for nobody for different Plumbing
anyway we've gone off the rails here
today
here's a call we had come in
what's up Theo this is uh Tristan from
North Carolina
Tristan thank you brother for calling
North Carolina beautiful
uh that's where Caleb Presley used to
live and
um play quarterback let's just say it
like that onward
I was wondering
is it gay
to sleep with a shirt but nothing below
the waist
um
is gay
is gay to sleep with a dude
that's the real litmus test I think
onward
let me know all right later okay you got
that one easy
uh
IPO
um I'm from Arkansas man and Hey Brother
and thank you for calling in man and
it's a beautiful state my buddy Justin
is from Arkansas and he likes to gun
down them gobblers
last night we let the liquor talk onward
they got this new law where you have to
to get on pornography
you got to verify your identity you know
to get on there and I'm 30 so I'm old
enough
but I just really don't want to put my
you know all my information on these
sketchy uh porn sites
so I was just wondering if you had any
contact information for that guy that
threw them good titties man if you could
just let me know get back with me please
yeah well I'll tell you the original
website maybe is your imagination
and that's the one if you want to brew
up a batch of damn knockers baby that's
it that'll do it
that's the one to use man that's that's
the internet God gave us right there is
that is that uh imagination it really is
you know and that was the internet that
we had before we had the internet
and I think it's interesting I was just
talking about this on the previous call
and I'll try to be more serious here
about it or something or for some reason
I'm feeling more serious suddenly
um
because I've had this same instance
you know I was keyed on the only fan and
I was trying to get on there and it said
you well we need your information I said
whoa whoa whoa buddy
whoa whoa whoa
I'm just trying to you know
Daddy's trying to
you know I'm just trying I'm just trying
to
you know robust you know I'm just trying
to robust myself you know or really you
know I'm trying to see something you
know but it's funny I didn't want to put
my information in so I said oh I can't
do this I don't want anybody knowing I
don't want one of these sketchy sites
knowing my information
but I'm willing to
blast my my DNA which is the the
greatest information I have of myself
I'm going to leave that in the damn
neighbor's yard
if it means getting that nudie off
you know
if it means churning up that gizm
ET food my kid
so that's I found it interesting too man
I don't think there's a way around it I
think it's good if I I'm you know I
think it's good
I think pornography really
and I'm not saying I haven't watched I'm
not saying I haven't seen it in the past
week cuz
you know
but I think it has definitely done a lot
of harm to men
and I think it's going to be something
that it's funny because would you want
your kid on there
there are people like I don't know if my
cat if I catch my kid on porn I'm gonna
beat whoop his butt
but then they'll be on porn
now I'm not pointing at these people
saying they're I'm any different I'm
just saying it's interesting
so it's a lot there's there's some lines
out there that we as men we gotta start
to we gotta start to
you know we gotta put that steam in the
kettle
because there's something else that
happens when you're when you're when
you're when you keep all your all your
uh your men in the boat
you see like you sail with a you feel
like a tribe
when someone looks in your eyes you
were of what you're supposed to be of
you know I just don't know I don't know
if a little bit of bit of the world gets
sad if we're just squeezing out
you know if we're just you know
Frost and invisible strudels out in the
world
but um
anyway I'm okay with the porn laws I'm
okay with blockers on my phone and
computer because those help me
you know give me a little bit of a space
before I'm about to go do something
naughty to myself God
anyway what else do we got uh let's see
if we can get another call here
what's going on Theo this is uh Chris
from Dallas Dallas Texas what's up
Christopher from Dallas and thank you
for calling brother appreciate you
onward it's the black guy you know
living out here okay a black guy thank
you for calling buddy
uh her brother I don't know uh Chris
thank you for calling bud
um quick question man I've been trying
to go through some things
um
I'm trying to find meaning
um right now I've been trying to build
my life and start my life you know
and I really can't find the funds it
seems like I don't know where to look
you know I don't know what I'm looking
to
get that starter pack you know because
life creates you know family and
house and stuff like that so
it's been still kind of bummed out super
anxious about it you know about anxiety
I just want to see you know what kind of
words you got for me then
keep my head high keep everything on up
and up and you know
gang baby thank you for calling Chris
um
you know we got a guy coming in who
knows a lot about meaning uh
he's a smart guy this guy John varvaki
is going to come in and talk
I'm gonna get to sit down with him I'm a
little nervous because he's very smart
um
or he has a lot of information you know
we all judge smart can be a relative
term
um
but yeah find it having meaning is
important
you know and I think there is a and if
we want meaning these days we have to
find it in ourselves
um
and and also in having a sense of
community you know I think there's two
searches that uh that a man goes on
there's one is his own search how do I
have meaning
it's scary to ask yourself too man do I
mean anything
do I mean anything to myself
man that's a scary one isn't it do I
mean anything to myself
man that's interesting
if I'm thinking to myself man do you
meet do you
do you mean anything to yourself wow
I think my answer or what I'm feeling
right now I feel like I haven't at times
I haven't meant anything to myself
but I'm not trying to make self-pity
um
I feel sorry to my to myself not for
myself I feel sorry to myself
that I had uh that I had chosen or that
I was feeling that way
foreign
because
um
man that I'm having trouble getting the
because
I don't maybe I don't have it because
right now I just feel like man I'm sorry
that I that
that I
I know it's weird to think that I'm
talking to myself
but
hey man I'm sorry that I
that I didn't that that you didn't mean
man I'm getting a little confused but
I'm trying not to do do I mean something
to myself
there's been times where I didn't mean
anything to myself
and I think at the time I didn't know
how to mean something to myself
I didn't even know that I didn't
I just felt a certain way
uh that I I think it was just sitting
low self-worth
you know I wasn't worth a lot to myself
um
and now I think that I feel a little bit
I feel less of that
I'm able to say back to my previous self
hey man I'm sorry that uh I'm sorry you
felt that way
because that's not the truth
um
the truth is you've always meant
something to you
you just
weren't able to access it or weren't
aware of it
um
I don't know that that's a really
interesting question it's got me
I
it's hard it's hard to
show you what I'm thinking sometimes
um
or to know if you're able to follow
clearly with what I'm thinking or
feeling because I'm trying to feel it
and say at the same time that's hard for
me sometimes
um
but if you're thinking on this on a
different level
first of all I'm glad you're making this
call because you're thinking about it
yeah what do I mean it's something we
need to ask ourselves
you know what I'm glad you're making me
think what do I mean to me
do I mean anything to someone
am I doing something where I deserve to
mean something to someone am I creating
a a realistic environment
for meaning
I've struggled definitely struggled with
that
now if you're meaning how do I get
started in my life I'll tell you the the
best way if you're poor
because I grew up right there bro if you
poor walk outside
look next door bro
hey [__] that's me bruh
that's where I right there that was that
right there
I'm not saying no flex I'm not just
saying but this is how you get out of
that
this is the number one job way I finally
get out of that is go get you if you
don't have no possibility like if you're
smart and you're gonna have or if you I
don't want to say smart if you do well
at school that's one way
right
you can do this you can get you a job
uh that's one way to get out
here's another way if you're not that if
you don't love school if that's not
really your thing you still want to get
out of there but you don't want to do
something illegal get you a pressure
washer bro
100 percent cut get you that little
spray rig bro
go around drive to the nice neighborhood
the one you go trick-or-treating at you
know what's good
go door to door make you some nice
flyers or something say you pressure
walls right pressure walls is costly
it's cost you a few hundred bucks man to
get things washed up signed up
the wealthier people that have something
nice a lot of times they want to take
care of their nice stuff so they'll hire
you to do it that's the best method that
I've seen in my life of somebody who
didn't have that's one method I've seen
I'm sure there's countless others
but one that I would recommend
if you poor but you got some work ethic
how do I get to this neck how do I be a
business owner and look you're not going
to pressure wash your whole life but
that's going to get you started
but that's the best thing let me tell
you how it's pressure washer how much
how much for a decent
pressure
washer
oh bro they got the nice one right here
this 3200 PSI hell yeah bruh
that'll [__] part your hair bro
that'll part your scalp that [__]
dang though that thing's three thirty
three hundred thirty dollars so you can
get you a low end hog runner for uh for
300 you win the game
now you might want to get an LLC after
you do your first couple runs if you get
somebody to work for you you might want
to get some insurance but
out the gate man
if you get up and start working with
this thing you can make some money so
that's my current tip people may say
well if you got a good way that's not
drugs
are selling a
a poster weiner
and you want to tell somebody how to get
out the uh
out of the
poor neighborhood or get out of poverty
have some have some uh meaning it's a
it's a small way to have meaning but
anyway brother but those are some ways
that I've you know that is one way that
I've seen if you're looking for some way
to get out
um
but otherwise if you're just looking
generally for me and how do you get a
house that kind of man some of that
stuff will come but you know uh
but how to create meaning is a great
question
how to create meaning for myself
I think it's something I'm still you
know figuring out
uh I'm gonna think more about it though
and try to talk about it again
um thank you for the call
what's one other call that came in here
see about this
hey Theo uh this is Donnie from Tucson
Arizona and uh Donnie from Tucson
and I got uh busted for drugs and had to
go live with my mother there for six
months and
and I went to Santa Rita high school
over there and kids were uh fist
fighting
oh you want a box on me I'll [__]
fight you though and the Mexican kids
always talk like this though looking
straight at the sky
I'd be like dude are you talking to me
anybody [__] yeah I'm talking to you
like any they could have been talking to
anybody bro these dudes were talking
about an astronauts no dog I'm talking
the [__] uh
um
[__] nice Armstrong though the first
guy to walk on the moon I'm like do you
mean that's Neil Armstrong dude you're
like yeah whatever [__] you want
a [__] box
so I went over there to Santa Rita High
School
where they had alarms every day because
there was Mexicans fighting and doing
[Music]
um
Mexican Fighting
and they we'd have to lay down on the
ground because the the alarm would go
off the uh
it was Riot alarms you have to lay down
and eat a burger while you were laying
down so that was lunch every day uh
onward anyway sorry making this about me
I just had a question man
um
so I've been in a relationship with this
girl for three years and
she just cheated on me
and
a relapse man I started taking Xanax
again and she's the reason I got off of
it but
after I found out she did that another
man was touching her
I don't know I just
lost it man and
I don't know what to do
I've taken two weeks off of work right
now and I'm trying to get back on my
feet but I just can't stop thinking
about her and can't
can't focus anymore man I'm just
I'm feeling very lost you know I'm only
22 and I don't know what to do
I hope you hear this man I know you get
a lot of calls and gang brother I
appreciate it man thanks for the call
and I'm sorry that you're uh going
through this moment
um
yeah that's that that's tough because
then you got two addictions really
um
and it sounds like the addiction really
I'm no bro I'm no scientist you know it
I'm no uh medicine man
or therapist
but a lot of times I thought I had a
drug problem
but a lot of my drug use was instigated
by interactions with women
right so a certain thing would happen
with a woman I would feel some rejection
or I would feel some type of way or I
couldn't communicate and I then I would
do do using drugs
so my really had kind of two addictions
I had an addiction to to
I had an addiction to a relationship
staying in a certain space and if it got
out of that space I couldn't I was I was
off the rails
and then to help myself I would use a
drug you know to help put some control
because some things about drugs some
drugs it's like I just want to control
how I feel right now
that's it's about control talking about
sometimes being [__] yeah it's like
the byproduct of that but I want to
control how I feel right distance it's
about control
that's why I didn't love drink I Like
Cocaine [__] I wanna [__] I'm on a
[__] Fair
okay
that's what all you know
um
anyway I don't know if I'm I don't know
if I'm being of any survey let me listen
more time after I found out she did that
another man was touching her
I don't know I just
lost it man and
I don't know what to do
I've taken two weeks off of work right
now and I'm trying to get back on my
feet but I just can't stop thinking
about her and can't
can't focus anymore man I'm right so
right there you're saying I can't stop
thinking about her so that's really the
impetus of the issue you know
[Music]
um
man I think there's there's you know
there's there's groups called sex and
love addiction intimacy addiction that
kind of thing you may reap something
from it you know it's people that
you know they call it sex and love
addiction but a lot of times it's just
you know I remember if a woman broke up
with me or treated me some type of way I
I man I couldn't [__] breathe brother
it shook me
because the only way I valued myself was
if I had some if there was a value from
a woman that's the only way that I
valued myself
in the second that gun uncertain or they
weren't they didn't value me or they
valued somebody else oh gosh brother
I was
I didn't have a chance man
I didn't have a chance because I didn't
have anything else that was holding me
up
the only thing that was holding me up
was how you what you felt about me or if
you thought I was oh if you thought I
was okay that's the only thing that was
that was my legs
and once that was gone
man
now this was at a different time in my
life
you know but I can really relate to that
man I'm sorry that you're dealing with
that
um now AA still helped me
and that may be a great place for you to
start
would be to hit some AAA meetings man
you can start with those on Zoom you can
even keep your camera off in some of
them so if you just want to sit there
and listen
um
and listen for the similarities not the
differences that's what people say when
you go into those rooms I'm not trying
to preach at you I'm not trying to tell
you what to do
uh
uh but yeah
God that's a harrowing pain too
because I think I always when I was you
it was always so hard it felt like to
get a woman to care about me and once
one did man it was
oh [__]
you know it was just it was a lot anyway
I'm getting into a little
I don't know if it's self-pity but I'm
getting into a little something that's
you know I just wanna
um
make sure that I'm keeping it focused on
you but uh I love you brother and keep
your head up and uh you can do it but
you have to take some action
okay or that kind of stuff will stick
around that same behavior will happen
the next time that you have a
relationship that happens
um
all right let's take another call here
hey Theo it's Gavin hands from a little
bit lower from Albany New York Gavin up
there in Albany bro Albany or Albany
and that's where they used to have the
Albany
um a lot of racing dogs or bred up there
and born
so if you like to play the pups
you can do it there let's hear more and
today I have an incident I'm a Christmas
tree farmer and today I'm an incident
with B oh yeah boy you damn God's
Gardener baby
dang brother
you're Santa's Johnny Appleseed homie
you're damn growing Christmas trees baby
that's what's up I salute you
God we need more people like you
all these other [__] ass trees [__]
if every tree was a Christmas tree oh
Lord how good would we feel onward today
I'm incident with bees and I got stung
and I went into Epileptic shock and I
Epileptic shock baby
hell yeah I used to listen to James
Brown baby and that [__] would [__]
do it to me my own word I was alone I
complete I was passed out on the ground
I feel good
[Music]
and the only thing that I had going in
my ears I feel good
I knew that I would get back
was through my headphones was your
podcast
and I was like I gotta live for this I
gotta I gotta stay alive for this and I
just want to thank you because you
helped me control my breathing be able
to call 9-1-1 and I'd say you saved my
life so thank you very much have a great
one
Amen brother
that's what's up brother
a cat
oh
yeah man well I'm glad you're alive baby
yes we nor can dude I I'm just glad
you're alive brother and that's it dude
sometimes you want to have something
that's just keeping you at a comfortable
level
and I'm glad it was a low-key episode
where we were able to just be there for
you as you laid there
and [__] just took it
from those bees and I hope they weren't
men that's the gayest thing I think
about getting stung by bee it's like was
that a male
I don't know if you've ever had that
where you just it [__] two of them
sting you and you're like God
well that two men like somebody at least
checked that thing
you know check that thing for that
little
for that honey clown baby that
check that b for some cooter you know
but anyway I don't know that shouldn't
matter
it shouldn't matter God does what he
wants
um yeah look I I don't know where else
we go from this
[Music]
um
there's you know there's a lot of great
calls that have come in I tried my best
sometimes you know
people want different things out of
different calls it's always great to
think together
um
you know things in my own life I've been
dealing with or
no struggling I've been struggling still
you know just worried about my own ego
you know it's that can be very scary uh
I've been dealing with some social
anxiety a little bit
[Music]
um
and uh
uh some anger sometimes I you know still
battling anger a lot of anger
and I noticed that my anger isn't
attached it doesn't attach to the right
thing something will come up and an
unnecessary amount of angst and anger
will be attached to that and it's like
man this ain't hey buddy this anger
doesn't fit right here you know and so
I'm having to kind of look at that and
talking with my therapist about that
like why is what am I doing here you
know
and having to talk to myself hey buddy
you shouldn't be this upset about this
thing so there's some something in here
doesn't isn't correct right or is it not
correct but isn't it's not
aligned the right way so let's look at
this and figure it out but I love the
call about meaning
um
yeah some great uh things for you guys
to think about and give us some
suggestions if you have a good
suggestion to one if you're if you grew
up in poverty you grew up in a poor
Place what's a good way to get to
another level
um
I know people say real estate and stuff
like that and but something like that
you you got to get to a level where you
can afford that kind of money that's
still
you know having some money to put into
something like a you know even 10 or 20
grand to put onto a a an apartment or
home or that that we got to get we're
talking a step before that and we don't
want to sell drugs or pills or DIY
um
abortions or anything like that we want
to play play Within the rules much as we
can you know what I'm saying but we're
praise God
um all right man I love you guys uh
be good to yourselves
and we're gonna go out here uh
you know sometimes we don't even know
the letter something we we we got the
letter we can't even say the words
sometimes we don't have it all figured
out I think this is a perfect episode
for me for that you know there's a
perfect episode when I asked the guy for
you know he was trying to tell me how to
get to the place and he just uh
uh uh
uh
[Music]
um cat
you just don't have the words uh
uh but you try they come in they get
filled and you're like oh damn flea
market well damn
film cat no cat
really well yes this flea market
you know we just try to stay alive and
stay hopeful until
uh the vagueness clears
or until we're giving a stronger sign
you know
yeah
so I hope you guys are able to do that
if there's something you're struggling
with I'll be able to just stay in there
and hold the line
um
until you get a stronger answer and I
think I believe that if I ask for a
stronger answer I will get a stronger
answer
you know I really believe that
um thank you guys thank you for the
support uh uh hope you guys have a
wonderful week good luck to everybody
with their children starting school and
I know a lot of the moms the second they
get that child out the door boy they put
on that cardi B
or that Shania Twain cardi B is just
just a single woman Shania Twain
that's all that is you know that
um
but yeah good luck to all you parents
who um
who who are sending your children off
and and uh and praise God all you Young
Bucks and young lassies that are
starting up getting your schooling going
still stay alive
you know do your best
back off the fentanyl we don't need it
and um yeah anyway I don't know I don't
know what I'm talking about uh thank you
guys for for being a part of my uh for
being a part of this podcast and just
for being along with some of this
journey it's just been so exciting and
um and interesting you know and I hope I
just uh uh I hope we hope we continue to
um get to learn more as our lives evolve
you know and uh you guys be good to
yourself baby okay
[Music]
feel I'm
friends I must be
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life I found I
can feel it in my bones
but it's gonna take